so I'm not going to sort of like rehash everything
that happened during our vacation, but there
are a couple things that I, I do want to get
to.
One of them is that Donald Trump appeared
to neurologically malfunction during a speech
for the right wing on campus group turning
point USA.
Donald Trump slurred his way through this
speech.
He went on a very strange rant about windmills,
which I will get to, but the moment that is
attracting a lot of attention and also garnering
demands for a full neurological workup at
a proper medical facility is the moment where
Donald Trump slurred his language at the exact
time that here he appeared to spasm or twitched
his shoulders.
Now the audio alone doesn't do justice.
So we've been playing the video for our television
audience to see.
Let's now actually listen to, it's just the
12 second clip.
And let me begin by wishing you a beautiful
egg.
Look here.
Remember this jury member, they were trying
to take Christmas out.
This is getting very difficult to ignore,
to pretend that everything is fine, but once
again, even if you excuse this particular
moment, the behavior, the rest of the was
odd.
Now as far as this goes, which some people
are calling again in neurological malfunction
or some kind of a spasm, I got emails from
some folks saying, David, the the condition,
tardive dyskinesia seems to maybe, uh, be
a fit here.
Although when I look that up, it's not totally
clear to me that it is, and of course I, I
am no medical professional.
Even if you excuse this moment, the behavior,
the entire speech was odd.
Here's the part where Donald Trump talked
about windmills.
He's talking about wind farms.
He's still calling them windmills, making
absolutely no sense whatsoever.
And economy based on wind.
I never understood when did I know windmills
very much.
I've studied it better than anybody I know.
It's very expensive.
They're made in China and Germany, mostly,
very few made here.
Almost not.
But they're manufactured tremendous.
If you're into this tremendous fumes, gases
are spewing into the atmosphere.
You know, we have a world, right?
So the world is tiny compared to the universe.
So tremendous, tremendous amount of fumes
and everything.
You talk, you talk about the carbon footprint,
fumes is spewing into the air rights spilling.
Whether it's in China, Germany, it's going
into the SRA.
There're everything, right?
So they make these things and then they put
them up.
Add.
If you own a house within vision of some of
these monsters, your house is worth 50% of
the price.
They're noisy, they kill the birds you want
to see at birth grade, you just go take a
look.
A bird graveyard go under a windmill some
day.
It went on from there.
I think he referred to China as Jina, which
is really weird.
He's looking at windmills very strongly.
He studied them very much.
This is that repetitive overuse of certain
linguistic crutches that we've observed with
Donald Trump before.
Most people don't know that the world is tiny
compared to the universe.
That's another one of his linguistic crutches
that he uses when he seems to sort of get
confused, meandering about where he's going,
calling wind farms monsters is just an odd
touch.
And then here is, um, that that sort of slowed
down slurring, uh, from Trump, inclusive of
that spasm moment,
maybe on the low side.
So if anybody wants to be a nice conservative
talk, show host is not a bad living, I will
say.
But I have to say he's a very unique guy and
he's a great man and he's been a great friend,
so thank you to rush.
Thank you.
Yeah,
and let me begin by wishing you a beautiful,
I'd look here.
Remember this jury member they were trying
to take Christmas out of Christmas.
You're a member,
so once again you can say the Christmas spasm
wasn't a spasm that what Trump Trump considers
comedy in some way.
Well, what about the slurring and the total
incoherence about windmills?
The question that's coming up more and more
is if this keeps getting worse, if he continues
to seemingly deteriorate, what will he be
like by the time of the general election debates
against the eventual democratic nominee, and
maybe maybe more importantly before our vacation,
Donald Trump tease the idea that he might
participate in the debates.
Maybe he would do more debates, maybe he would
do fewer.
Maybe he would do none at all depending on
what he wants.
He said his president, it's ultimately up
to him.
Is all of that related to starting to lay
the groundwork to just not do any debates
because he would come completely unglued during
a 90 minute debate.
I don't know the answer to that Democrats.
What I do know is that Democrats would really
have to run someone terrible to come away
looking like they lost the debate to this
guy.
Trump can barely put together a coherent thought
at this point in time, and I still wouldn't
put it past Democrats to nominate someone
that will make Trump not look that bad and
make it at least plausible that Donald Trump
is holding it together during the debates.
I hope that doesn't happen.
I think most of you understand what I'm talking
about and what I'm getting at, but continued
very bizarre behavior from Donald Trump.
Call it what you want.
I do want to hear from you.
What do you think went on in this video?
Leave a comment if you're watching on YouTube
or send me a tweet at Dee Pacman.